Alright! So, let's I mean, what we'd really like to get to
are algorithms for doing optimization, and I think to do that it's
helpful to do a quiz. So, here is a little a quiz
that I put together, I call it Optimize Me. And what I
want you to do is, is here's two different problems, there's two
different input spaces, two different functions, and I want you to find
the optimal x-star or something really close to it, if you can't
get it exactly right. So, the first question we've got the input
space x is the values one to 100. And the function that we're trying to optimize
is x mod 6 squared mod 7 minus the sin of x.
>> Holy cow.
>> Yeah, it's, it is an awesome looking function. Do you want to
see it? I, I might be able to plot it for you.
>> Sure, I'd love to see plots, because then
maybe I'll know how to figure out the answer.
>> Yeah oh yeah well maybe I should not then,
maybe I should wait until we already have an answer and then yeah,
let's, let's wait but I'll show you after it. It's, it's, it's crazy.
>> [Laughs]
>> Alright it's beautiful. So okay good, so and the
second problem we've got x as the set of real
numbers, so all, any, any possible number in the reals.
And the function that we're trying to optimize is negative
x to the 4th plus 1000x cubed minus 20x squared plus 4x
minus 6. Alright, so you understand
the questions? I understand the questions, yes.
>> Good, good luck with them.